hé bé dorcé collectionneuse de
collection par ce matin à faire
l'ouverture
accompagné de charlie 100 photographes à
l'affût à défiler chez balmain première
embuscade pour la plume et le regard
acéré db prennent de ce monde de
chiffons pour à la meilleure chaises
pour aller révérence des couturiers même
celle de balmain qui murmure-t-on ici
nabi pas moins d'une demi-douzaine de
têtes couronnées
non je ça peu près égale ça c'est du
retard en syrie
dans ce monde à l'envers où les
célébrités et les stars se tiennent tous
par terre et baie rempli sa gibecière
des couilles et d'information placé à
côté de pâtes là au fort de la soeur de
kindi alors qu'est une information de
première main
oui edwards maintiendra sa candidature à
la présidence des états unis
la longueur des ourlets l'intéressent -
finalement qu'une certaine atmosphère
qu'est ce que vous ressentez quand vous
écrivez un article sur la mode comme ça
parce qu'après tout d'amour vous pouvez
assassiné aventuriers ouest à signer
personne sauf que je me suis offert un
article qui soit intéressant et on est
sans problème
donc d'un côté c'est pas c'est pas
important parce que il n'ya que 1500
femmes au monde c'est bien un futur est
dans le pré c'est très important parce
qu'à travers dans l'essence il avait
démis encore les millions de gens
envoyés par cela si vous pratiquez une
collection quand même alors ça peut
avoir des conséquences justement si ce
problème de licence mais évidemment mais
ça c'est pas mon problème c'est leur
problème n'est pas que la presse puis
c'était quoi que ce soit si les gens ont
du talent en examen puis c'est tout
c'est le problème des couturiers car ces
défilés de mode sont entre autres une
vaste opération publicitaire pour
maintenir à l'éclat de leurs noms qu'il
menait affichées sur des foulards des
bagages du prêt-à-porter et toutes
sortes de produits
et l'on comprend mieux les attentions
dont est entouré et b d'orsay dont les
chroniques sont lus dans le monde entier
elle s'en défend mais elle a la dent
dure et cette année elle a intitulé son
article sur dior habillement
on devine aussi l' angoisse de pierre
cardin qui lui a vendu 550 et une fois
son nom
des champions
un petit chapeau là
et
pas si vite
donc partent à l'assaut
m
à terme des 8 par toi vite
non
en
voilà
et puis un pèlerinage nous plaçons
l'endroit exact où mademoiselle chanel
surveiller sans être vu le défilé les
spectateurs coco chanel qui elle n'avait
pas peur de voir ses idées décembre dans
la rue c'est que au fur et à mesure que
les femmes dont thomas d'il ya plus
pressants ils savent également vont
disparaître bon alors il n'y aura plus
besoin de faire des trois fois des
essayages et tout ça donc ce côté qui
avait encore une toute petite base
réelle va partir et à ce moment là
évidemment on va dire que ce sera la
couture ce sera plutôt les idées comme
une e-card un laboratoire d'idées qui
s'appliqueront à prêt à diffuser pour un
grand développeur pendant les
collections un rite le ritz aussi
classique que la robe de mariée
bilodeau dernier
c'est assez
mais ce parc
l'enfant chéri des chroniqueuses yves
saint laurent
oh
oui très et même après ses soucis on
n'est pas encourager autant l'abandonner
c'est beaucoup trop difficile et
beaucoup trop de heurts
or des portes
alors c'est un espèce de mécénat donc si
c'est la haute couture veille qui ont
collectionné très compliquée par exemple
si j'en avais deux ou trois je pousse
vie les a beau vendre et mauvais papier
compte robot chiffon un match qui durera
même si personne n'a plus les moyens de
s'offrir ces robes laboratoire car la
roue volera toujours leur esprit